well joining me now for central London
is Lord Paton the former governor of
Hong Kong who oversaw the colony being
handed back by Britain to China at 22
years ago
Lord pattern thanks very much indeed for
your time this afternoon first of all
what's your reaction to those scenes
that we saw in Hong Kong last night I'm
extremely sad about them because of
course they're not at all like the
earlier demonstrations by students which
were peaceful on the whole I think it's
extremely regrettable that there was
violence yesterday and I don't think
that's acceptable and I think it
actually takes away from the really
important part of what's been happening
which you referred to earlier in the
report that hundreds of thousands of
people up to two million people have
been demonstrating peacefully and
lawfully about their rights as citizens
which they're anxious to retain I think
the problem when violence creeps in as
it plainly has for whatever reason is
that it takes away from the from the
credibility of that campaign by hundreds
of thousands of people I very much hope
the government will among other things
have a public inquiry into the
demonstrations that have taken place
over recent weeks and to the way they've
been policed and include in that what
happened yesterday because everybody
should be keen to know what exactly
happened why the police behaved as they
did above all who was actually
responsible for the violence well yes
and correct me if I'm wrong but I
understand that you have a bit some
sympathy with one of the issues at the
heart of these protests this
controversial
extradition bill which was was
introduced some concerns that that might
be used to send political dissidents to
China given that you have some sympathy
with the protesters do you worry then
that their argument has now been
undermined well I worry that the point
that's been made by all those peaceful
demonstrators don't forget the last but
one of those demonstrations with about 2
million people was led by people in
wheelchairs families lawyers business
people manual workers the whole
community was taking part because for
them
the extradition law that was proposed
demolished the
a wall between the rule of law in Hong
Kong and what passes for the law in
mainland China now that's the biggest
issue the fact that it's probably the
case that a few students behaved so
stupidly and were violent even though
you can I suppose understand their
frustrations even if you don't agree
with the way they express them we
shouldn't allow that violence to take
away from the biggest issue but which is
the way in which Hong Kong is gradually
having the noose tightened around it by
mainland China well yes and what do you
think mainland China will do now we've
heard that serious illegal actions have
they been described by by China and they
talked about the protesters trampling on
the rule of law so what do you think
their next step could be well I think
it's very odd to hear Chinese officials
talking about trampling on the rule of
law when they incarcerated about a
million people in Xinjiang I hope that
the Chinese authorities the Hong Kong
Macao Affairs Office which looks after
Hong Kong at a distance the Foreign
Ministry will be rather careful about
what they say and I hope that they will
stop suggesting that the joint
declaration doesn't have any relevance
after 1997 the joint declaration was a
treaty signed by Britain and signed by
China in good faith and it goes on until
2040 47 it gives us every right to talk
about what's happening in Hong Kong to
discuss it with China to discuss it with
the Hong Kong authorities that is our
right under international law and if
China says forget about it what they're
actually saying is you can't trust us to
keep our word well yes and that's a
joint declaration one country two
systems' was agreed as you said in 1997
when you left as Hong Kong governor what
is your feeling about that do you feel
that it's being seriously undermined by
China at the moment I think it is being
at the moment I think to be fair to
China and before this president before
President Xi Jinping the Chinese
authorities had been pretty good about
Hong Kong not everything was perfect
they choked back on the development of
democracy in Hong Kong but by and large
I think Hong Kong you could still regard
as operating with a high degree of
autonomy and
the rule of law with all the freedoms
you'd associate with an plural and open
society I think that has been brought
into question since 2014 when to be
frank I think the Chinese government the
regime in Beijing were unsettled by the
democracy demonstrations which were
peaceful unlike what happened last night
with a few people who I think behaved
really foolishly in smashing through
into the Legislative Council building
and allegedly because they didn't think
that it really represented them trashing
it that was not a sensible way to behave
and I'm sure that more sensible members
of the community who were taking part in
those demonstrations those peaceful
demonstrations in the hundred thousand
over the last few weeks will make that
plain to them China is called this a
domestic issue and says that Britain
shouldn't interfere you were saying that
Britain should have the right given the
fact that it was a joint declaration
between Britain and China that
determines the future structure for Hong
Kong so what would you want Britain to
do now well not only should Britain
intervene should have the right but it
does have the right and I'm pleased that
Jeremy Hunt the Foreign Secretary said
what he did say and this is an
international treaty China is obliged to
it until 1997 we were obliged to honor
our commitments to the people of Hong
Kong and explain what we were doing to
China after 1997 until 2047 China is
obliged to explain to the people of Hong
Kong and to us how it's keeping its
commitments to the citizens of Hong Kong
and it can't simply walk away from that
unless it wants the rest of the world to
believe that it can't be trusted to keep
its word well trying to be concerned
about contagion of some kind elsewhere
in the country well the Chinese keep on
telling us that the China dream is
something that everybody can share but
they seem jolly unsettled when anybody
else has a views of their own or wants
to have free speech or wants to look up
things on the internet they're very
concerned that people shouldn't know
what happened in Tiananmen Square in
1989 so they have to get their I have to
get their story right the truth of the
matter is the China is an old-fashioned
Leninist auteur
autocracy China has done extremely well
economic economically over the last 30
or 40 years that doesn't mean that its
system of government is one which is
exportable and it certainly doesn't mean
that it can trash the freedoms of Hong
Kong and Hong Kong's leader Carrie Lam
suspended this extradition bill that
we've referred to protesters want it
scrapped completely they want her to
stand down do you think she should go
well I'm not going to get into that
argument that's a question of her partly
although she's obviously there because
China wants her there what is absolutely
plain I think is first of all all she's
got to do is say I'm not just suspending
the bill I'm not gonna reintroduce it
the bill is dead secondly I think she
should as I said earlier she should have
a public inquiry into the whole question
of the policing of demonstrations
including what happened yesterday I
think that would if it was transparent
and open and conducted by a senior
independent well-regarded local figure I
think that would help to remove some of
the anxieties and concerns people have
on both sides both about the way that
peaceful demonstrations are policed and
about the way that some demonstrations
haven't been fully peaceful and should
be made Polly peaceful in the future 22
years it's you set sail from Hong Kong
completing your stand as the last
Governor there how do you feel seeing
those pictures that we saw yesterday and
seeing the protests over the last few
weeks how does it feel for you well I
feel very bad about the protests that
happened yesterday but when I look at
what's happened over the last few weeks
I feel a great sense of shame not not
because of anything happening in Hong
Kong I think people have behaved
extraordinarily bravely and decently but
they behaved seriously and I can't help
but compare that with what's happening
in British politics I think we have some
lessons to learn from those hundreds of
thousands of people who've behaved so
bravely and so sensibly in order to
stand up for the balance between
political and economic freedom in Hong
Kong
I wish the state of our debate in this
country was rather more serious do you
want to elaborate on that a little bit
further
well what I would I'd like to say is
here we are in a debate about the future
of our country which is full of
mendacity and delusion and every day
there come another set of delusions at
present we seem to be thinking that
there are forests as somebody said of
money bearing trees out there waiting to
shower their gifts on the rather limited
number of members of the Conservative
Party I think what we're seeing is
serious government departing from
traditional conservative values and
forgetting about the national interest
and I think that's deeply saddened but
obviously the main thing I'm concerned
about at the moment is the future of
Hong Kong I hope that here in Britain we
can behave bit more sensibly that's
rather a limited amount that I can do
about that